bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public 90
minutes de débat de chronique et de
reportage pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et voici
le sommaire de ce 15 janvier après les
premiers pas de son nouveau Premier
ministre et le premier quak du
gouvernement resserré avec les propos
d'Amélie ou DEA ctera sur les profs du
public non remplacé Emmanuel Macron
revient en pleine lumi hier cette
semaine avec une conférence de presse en
primetime demain est-ce le rendez-vous
avec la nation annoncé en en décembre et
puis surtout comment Gabriel hatal
peut-il réformer le pays avec une
majorité toujours plus friable à
l'Assemblée on répond entre autres à ces
questions dans une minute et puis pour
notre second thème volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour gros plan sur la
crise du marché de l'immobilier et du
logement avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt le nombre de prêt desgringoles
130 milliards d'euros l'an dernier c'est
mo-s 40 % sur 1 an pour savoir si cette
crise est vraiment historique si elle
est mondiale ou franco-française et puis
surtout quel levier activé pour en
sortir ne ratez pas notre second débat
dans 3ois quarts d'heure mais d'abord ce
qu'il faut attendre de cette conférence
de presse présidentielle avec Jérôme
Rabier il ne s'est pas prêté à
l'exercice depuis avril 2019 après la
crise des gilets jaunes Emmanuel Macron
tiendra demain une conférence de presse
que l'Élysée promet comme xxl et qui va
donc lui permettre de répondre à toutes
les questions des journalistes en prime
time le président de la République
pourra ainsi détailler la feuille de
route du nouveau gouvernement même si
pour l'instant peu de détails ont filtré
y compris dans son camp nous donnera
sûrement plus d'informations ce
soir à l'Élysée euh mais évidemment ce
sera un moment fort et qui va comme il
l'annoncé d'ailleurs c'est un tournant
du quinquena
différ dans ce il a changé gouvernement
changé de Premier ministre et pour
lancer une nouvelle impulsion certains
évoquent des annonces sur le plan
institutionnel et pourquoi pas même un
référendum mais dans les faits seul
l'Élisée sa quelle est la teneur du
propos alors côté opposition on s'en
prend surtout à la forme le président
reprenant la main après la nomination de
son premier ministre c'est vraiment
parfaitement inélégant j'allais dire
totalement contradictoire avec pratique
républicaine qui fait qu'on attend que
le premier ministre s'exprime bientôt
devant le Parlement dans un discours
politique général il considère que
celui-ci n'a pas de marge de manœuvre
c'est lui qui dicte les choses dans un
contexte où le pouvoir d'achat est la
première préoccupation des Français la
gauche espère des annonce après la
séquence remanement et prise de guerre
voilà ce que j'attends que le Président
de la République nous fasse enfin des
annonces concrètes qu'on sorte de sous
de cette séquence de communication et
qu'on nous dise maintenant qu'est-ce qui
va être fait pour que les Français leur
vie soit moins difficile que ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
le président devrait détailler comment
il compte concrètement traduire en acte
les grands concepts de réarmement du
pays et de régénération évoqué lors de
ses vœux du 31 décembre dernier avant de
laisser le nouveau gouvernement à la
manœuvre pour mettre en place ses
chantiers la conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron le quakoua casterra
mais aussi la stratégie de Gabriel hatal
pour éventuellement contourner le le
Parlement l'assemblée national beaucoup
de thèmes à aborder avec Frédéric dab
bonsoir bienvenue le directeur général
de l'Ifop Lucile Schmid bonsoir et
bienvenue vice-présidente du cercle de
réflexion la fabrique écologique et
auteur de ce livre Emmanuel Macron à
contretemps paru aux éditions Bayard
Jean-Sébastien Ferjou bonsoir et
bienvenue le fondateur et le directeur
d'Atlantico Mathieu croissandau bonsoir
Mathie bienvenue éditorialiste politique
Frédéric dabich commence avec vous
est-ce qu'on vous avez entenduel bonpard
est-ce qu'on peut espérer ou attendre
des annonce de la part du président de
la République est-ce que c'est le lieu
pour le faire conférence de press oui
peut être le lieu une conférence de
presse il a peu usé de ce moyen de
contact avec les Français par
l'intermédiation des journalistes c'est
pas un précdent qui comme Charles de GA
ou jean- franc bidou a usé ou même
François mitéran a usé de nombreuses
conférences de presse il avait annoncé
hein le 31 décembre si on reprend son
verbatam exact plus de résultats plus
d'efficacité plus de détermination et
j'aurai l'occasion dans les prochaines
semaines de vous dire comment je dis un
peu mal mais comment mettre en œuvre ces
différents défis il y a eu un premier
étage de la fusée avec ce remanimement
et cette nomination d' un jeune premier
ministre qui a créé on va dire un petit
effet dans dans l'opinion publique mais
ce n'est pas suffisant effectivement il
faut des annonces il faut pour le
président sortir de cette annus
horibilis qui est l'année 2023 il a
peut-être réussi avec un changement de
gouvernement mais on sait très bien que
les Français sont pas sur une logique de
casting sont sur une logique de résultat
le pouvoir d'achat c'est en effet une
des premières préoccupations des
Français je corrige un petit peu
derrière la question de la santé et
quasiment au même au même niveau que la
question
sécuritaire c'est vrai aussi et j'ai
entendu ce qui a été dit que ça rappelle
un petit
peu ce qui sé passé en 2017 où Emmanuel
Macron avait coupé l'herbe sous le pied
de son premier ministre et ça son
discours de politique Gén ne dites pas
tout de de la première répon mais bon a
pas de sou parce évidemment on des
annonces les Français attendent parce
que la parole présidentielle n'est pas
complètement démonétisé beaucoup de
Français ont parl de ses vœux et il y a
peut-être une attente qui monte lu je de
votre avis là-dessus qu'est-ce que vous
en attendez et puis peut-être aussi sur
la forme quoi c'est un exercice en
général il est pas trop mauvais Emmanuel
Macron dans ce genre d'exercice oui moi
je pense comme le dit Frédéric dabille
il y a sans doute une attente par
rapport à la parole d'Emmanuel Macron
mais par ailleurs il y a un paradoxe qui
qu'on a l'impression qu'elle est
surabondante donc il y a une attente et
il y a le fait qu'elle est surabondante
et qu'on attend toujours quelque chose
qui ne se passe pas et je pense qu' un
des risques par rapport à la nomination
de Gabriel Attal et à la première salve
de nomination gouvernementale c'est que
en accumulant les coups la semaine
dernière c'est dire un jeune premier
ministre et ensuite un gouvernement
resserré dans lequel il y avait Rachid
Dati en tête de gondole et puis ensuite
améli oua Castera qui fait cette espèce
d'erreur de parcours immédiate avec avec
la question de l'enseignement privé donc
on a l'impression qu'il y a eu une
accumulation de coups de théâtre et le
problème c'est que les coups de théâtre
successifs peuvent tuer justement
l'attention qu'on porte à ce que fait le
président de la République moi je pense
qu'il devrait expliquer peut-être des
choses concrètes mais surtout comment
est-ce qu'il travaille avec les autres
je sais pas comment est-ce qu'il va le
dire mais je pense que par exemple nous
expliquer que Gabriel hatthal est une
sorte de clone d'Emmanuel Macron mais en
quelque sorte aussi pour être son robot
c'estàdire on sait bien que c'est pas
lui qui a nommé son gouvernement par
exemple comment est-ce qu'il va
expliquer en tout cas c'est le discours
très critique vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis
moble tout Gabriel Attal l'a reconnu
lui-même il ne savait pas que Rachida
Dati serait au gouvernement et que il y
a quelque chose autour de l'idée de
comment est-ce que ça va travailler
ensemble et comment est-ce que le
travail collectif va pouvoir avoir lieu
al ça c'est une vraie question et et
jeansébas Sajou effectivement
on a un peu le sentiment que Emmanuel
Macron a pas voulu laisser la pleine
lumière trop longtemps à son premier
ministre est-ce qu'il y a de ça pour
vous oui bien sûr mais pour reprendre
l'expression du titre de votre livre
cette conférence de presse me paraît à
conttemps précisément parce que Frédéric
dabille faisait référence il doit y
avoir la déclaration de politique
générale du Premier ministre alors avec
ou sans vote de confiance c'est encore
un autre point mais ça n'empêche pas et
vous l'avez dit l'avait fait aussi pour
Édouard Philippe alors quand il y a une
majorité à absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale personne ne doute que le
Président de la République soit le chef
et de la majorité présidentielle et des
facto de la majorité parlementaire
depuis l'invention du quinena mais quand
on est dans une majorité relative moi je
pense que l'équilibre des institutions
change et c'est ce qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
semble pas avoir compris il se comporte
comme si il avait une majorité absolue
comme si tout procédait de lui
probablement vous parliez de sa manière
de travailler avec les autres il n'y a
pas que des éléments politiques il y a
aussi des éléments presque d'ordre
psychologique en quelque sorte il semble
considérer que si lui ne le fait pas
alors c'était un travers qu'on pu
partager certains de ses prédécesseurs
he de penser que si c'est pas eux qui le
font rien ne se fait et que tous les
autres sont des nazes sauf qu'on a envie
de lui demander mais quand même qui est
le sélectionneur qui est le
sélectionneur parce que ça fait quand
même 7 ans qu'il est président de la
République on est dans la 2e année ou
même bientôt la 3e de son 2e mandat qui
est le sélectionneur qui a choisi ce
mode de fonctionnement là et qui a
choisi ces gouvernements là et les
images voyez cell que vous diffusez dans
votre fusé moi ça me fait de plus en
plus penser à une espèce de monarchie
inversé vous avez un Premier ministre
qui rend visite dans le pays qui fait
des bonjours aux gens il est acclamé et
voilà ça évoque le prince et la
princesse de Gal et puis le Emmanuel
Macron se comporte comme si lui était le
locataire de darning Street ouais euh on
va parler de ce rendez-vous avec la
nation par a quand même ces termes qui
avaient été employés par par le chef de
l'État Mathieu bon ben finalement ça
débouche sur une conférence de presse et
oui quel déception on attendait une
série Netflix comme le promettait
l'entourage du président ces dernières
semaines le président pense qu'avalcade
avait même dit un conseiller au journal
l'opinion un autre avait invoqué le
conatus de Spinoza C cet effort
consistant à persévérer dans son nêre
malgré les désillusions et au final ben
ce mystérieux rendez-vous avec la nation
va se transformer en bonne vieille
conférence de presse vous conviendraz
que vu le teasing on attendait un truc
un peu plus fou quoi je plaisante mais
l'exercice paraît plus que jamais
nécessaire j'allais dire parce qu'on
avait quitté quand même le président de
la République avant Noël niant toute
crise dans l'émission C'est à vous sur
France 5 on l' retrouvé après les
vacances congédiant ellisabeth borne et
nommant Gabriel tal sans le début d'une
explication he de tweet c'est à peu près
tout ce qu'on a eu pour l'instant après
un début de second quinquena pour le
moins agité et contrarié on comprend
donc qu'il était tenté de passer à autre
chose oui et puis l'objectif j'ai
l'impression d'avoir déjà beaucoup dit
cette phrase mais bon c'est de fixer un
un cap pour la suite du quinquel ce
fameux cap ce cap dont tout le monde
rêve a commencé par les membres du camp
présidentiel dès que vous croisez un
député de la majorité premier truc qui
vous dit en baissant un peu les yeux
c'est il faut que le Président nous dise
où on va maintenant ce qui dit beaucoup
en creux sur le macronisme parce que
réélu en 2022 vous vous souvenez au
terme d'une campagne escamoté par les
crises internationales Emmanuel Macron
semble avoir bien du mal à donner un
sens à son action alors on le sait ses
communiquant développe des trésors
d'imagination pour rationaliser à
postériori ses décisions afin de nourrir
le grand récit du quinena comme ils
disent mais il peineent ces
communiquants pour des raisons qui sont
consubstantielles à leur patron parce
que faute de livre faute de travail
intellectuel faute de parti digne de ce
nom mais le seul qui sait ce que c'est
que le macronisme aujourd'hui c'est
Emmanuel Macron et puis difficultés
supplémentair le macronisme a évolué
avec le temps même si on peut nous faire
croire un retour aux origines au fameux
dépassement du clivage gauche- droite il
faut reconnaître qu'il s'est surtout
transformé en glissement à droite d'oute
à droite toute pardon ce qui mérite du
coup demain quelques explications est-ce
que pour autant on l'a évoqué rapidement
tout à l'heure ce ce l'exercice de la
conférence de presse est risqué pour le
président non non même si une si guerre
plié on le disait depuis 2017 le
pingpong avec les journalistes c'est
quand même un exercice qu' maîtrise
presque à la perfection mais au-delà des
punchlin au-delà des annonces tout
l'enjeu pour lui sera de tenter
d'éteindre les colères du passé de lever
les doutes sur le présent j'allais dire
et de poser des jalons pour la suite et
ça c'est quand même beaucoup moins
évident alors il y a un mot qu'on a
choisi de de mettre en avant dans ce
débat c'est le mot clarification est-ce
que pour vous c'est Frédéric dab c'est
c'est l'un des enjeux principaux de la
la conférence de presse demain soir
clarification je ne sais pas sil y a des
choses à clarifier alors bien sûr il y a
ce pourquoi as-til choisi ce ce premier
ministre revenir sur des polémiques
passées moi je pense par exemple à ses
propos sur Gérard pard enfin
certainement des questions moi je pense
que les Français ne sont pas scotchés et
obsédés par des quakques des polémiques
et cetera ils attendent je le disais des
résultats sur les grands sujets de l'UR
ils attendent un cap qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un cap c'est une ligne claire vers
lequel le pays peut se projeter mais
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ma
dire que on en est encore là voy ce que
je veux dire ou on en est encore là ça
montre ce ce paradoxe de ce Songo mandat
qui n'a pas vraiment commencé maisi j'ai
toujours en tête le verbtime D' d'une
sympathisante d'une électrice dans
marche qui disait en fait c'est un
mandat de 10 ans jamais on a compris du
côté de l'opinion publique la mécanique
entre le prer et le second mandat il y a
toute une série de raisons l'attente la
non campagne législative l'attente très
forte pour la nomination du gouvernement
cette semi-victoire semi-défaite aux
élections législatives et une année 2023
qui a été cannibalisée par cette
réformes des retraites qui était promise
mais dont les Français ne voulaient pas
entendre parler en gros 2 tiers à 34 la
clarification sur la nomination de
Gabriel hatal je vous parle sincèrement
est-ce qu'elle est vraiment nécessaire
c'est un Premier ministre qui fait des
des premiers pas alors en terme
d'enquête d'opinion plutôt réussie en
revanche c'est vrai que l'articulation
entre Emmanuel Macron et Gabriel hatal
Gabriel Atal qui doit diriger l'action
du gouvernement qui doit peut-être avoir
plus de champ on se souvient prenons un
exemple historique ancien mais qui a des
similitudes quand François mitteran
donne à la France comme il le disait son
plus jeune premier ministre Laurent
fabus juste après pendant plusieurs mois
il parle peu il parle même très peu il
est sur les les sur la dimension
internationale il prépare al c'est une
autre époque bien sûr sur réseau sa
grande émission avec Yv morouszi qui
avait lieu la rentrée 85 et il a laissé
le Premier ministre de l'époque se
déployer est-ce que Emmanuel Macron va
laisser gabrielal se déployer davantage
est-ce qu'il va le laisser aussi il va
laisser des ministres de son
gouvernement enfin bapasser ou passer
au-dessus de Gabriel Atel pour des
grandes décisions ça il y a peut-être
une clarification qui ne pourra pas
exprimer ouvertement
mais avec le temps ça sera vu
jeanébastien mais je PCE qu'on a déjà
enfin je suis d'accord avec toutes les
questions que pose Frédéric mais on a
déjà les réponses en réalité quand on a
Emmanuel Macron qui demande à ses
changera pas quoi c'est ce que vous vous
apprête dire avait dû changer mais c'est
pas seulement Emmanuel Macron tout le
monde est un peu s'il avait dû changer
il aurait déjà changé sa nature est très
présente malgré tout il demande à ses
minist d'être révolutionnaire mais en
même temps on voit bien que dès qu'il y
en a un qui dit quelque chose qui lui
déplaît on l'a vu avec RA abdoumak ça se
passe pas très bien donc je comprends
pas la logique qui est à leur demander
d'être révolutionnaire quand de toute
façon il décident quasiment de tout y
compris des directeurs de cabinet de
chacun et qu'en réalité la plupart des
décisions sont prises à l'Élysée à
l'exception de de deux trois grands
féodaux comme Gérald armenin c'est vrai
aussi pour le choix du directeur de
cabinet de de
Gabriel directeur du Trésor mais c'est
pour ça donc de tout faon Mo je pense
effectivement qu'il aurait gagné
certainement même si l'époque a changé à
s'inspirer de François mitteran qui
s'était mis en retrait la Constitution
lui offre un domaine réservé qui plus
est et pas des moindres avec la
politique étrangère mais là on voit un
Emmanuel Matron qui voudrait décider de
tout jusqu'à la moindre virgule au
moindre détail des décisions qui sont
prises dans l'état et je suis pas sûr
parce que Mathieu disait connaî-il la
réponse enfin il n'y a que lui qui sache
quelle est la nature du macronisme mais
est-il vraiment sûr au-delà de son
destin et de l'accomplissement de son
destin est-il vraiment sûr que lui-même
il mette un contenu politique si clair
que ça lucide schm sur la marge de
manœuvre potentielle de de Gabriel Atal
est-ce effectivement une on a entendu ça
dans le reportage d'ouverture une
mauvaise manière de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron de faire une conférence de presse
de qui qui est prévu XXL ça va durer on
sera on sera à l'antenne d'ailleurs en
direct demain pour vous la faire vivre
et la commenter avant et après ça peut
durer 2h peut-être 2h3 est-ce une
mauvaise manière quelques jours d'une
déclaration de politique générale de de
Gabriel Atal écoutez moi je suis plus
plus nuancé c'est-à-dire que je pense
que ce qui compte et on le voit
d'ailleurs dans cette photo derrière
vous c'est que il y a une relation de
confiance très forte entre Gabriel Atal
et Emmanuel Macron et que d'une certaine
manière si quelqu'un peut dire à
Emmanuel Macron tu devrais peut-être me
laisser un peu de marge de manœuvre
c'est Gabriel à c'està-dire que on voit
bien qu'Emmanuel Macron d'une certaine
façon n'écoute peut-être pas assez les
autres mais il a aussi dans ce
gouvernement au fond dit j'écarte ceux
dans lesquels je ne peux pas avoir
confiance par rapport à la loi migration
par exemple et donc cette question de la
confiance donnée à Gabriel Atal qui est
quelqu'un qui l'a choisi seul puisque on
le sait s'il avait consulté largement
personne ne lui aurait conseillé de
prendre Gabriel Atal comme premier
ministre donc je pense qu'on peut
compter sur une relation très proche qui
n'avait évidemment pas avec ellisabeth
borne et en ce sens moi je prends le
pari que Gabriel Attal peut nous
surprendre au-delà du formalisme
j'observe que beaucoup de critiques sont
émises pour dire il n'est pas respecté
d'ailleurs Gérald Armana va lui faire la
peau très rapidement Bruno Le Maire et
cetera moi franchement je pense que
Gabriel Attal a toutes les capacités
pour justement profiter de son capital
auprès de l'opinion dont Frédéric Daab
parlait et que au fond on peut penser à
un scénario non pas où Emmanuel Macron
changerait mais où la relation forte
entre le Premier ministre et le
président de la République pourrait nous
surprendre sur un nouvel équilibre par
exemple ce qui peut être intéressant sur
la deuxième salve gouvernementale c'est
que Gabriel Atal apparaisse responsable
de cette deuxè salve gouvernementale
ministre délégué secrétaire d'État h
é je P ça poserait un problème si
Gabriel Atal était incarné une ligne
politique c'estàd si si c'était un choix
politique de de ligne de le nommer à
Matignon si c'était un allié puissant si
c'était un courant puissant au sein du
macronisme ça serait une mauvaise
manière qui lui est faite de ne pas
pouvoir déployer sa ligne d'une certaine
façon mais comme il y a pas une feuille
de papier à cigarette et que Gabriel
Atal c'est plutôt distingué dans une
forme de savoir-faire et de faire savoir
les deux hein pas seulement la
communication mais il aussi un
savoir-faire dans la prise de décision
mais qui sont en ligne avec avec ce que
dit le président mais il y a pas
forcément de de de de mauvaise manière
mais d'utant que on peut on peut
attendre peut-être d'ailleurs des des
quelques annonces qui seront ensuite
détaillés par par gb latal dans sa
déclaration de politique générale Jean
Sébastien Ferjou oui ça peut ça peut se
s'activer comme ça oui bien sûr mais je
suis pas certain enfin Frédéric dabille
rappelez les attentes des Français ça
sont pas sur des annonces en soi que
voulez-vous annoncer en matière de
pouvoir d'achat que voulez-vous ce sont
des faits structurels le pouvoir d'achat
c'est la manière dont l'économie
française existe c'est 40 ans
désindustrialisation c'est la parité de
l'euro enfin c'est beaucoup de choses
qui ne se gèent pas par l'instauration
d'un service national universel ou je ne
sais quel autre symbolle qui peuvent
avoir du sens en soi mais qui ne sont
pas nécessairement c'est pas ça qui va
changer l'insécurité dans les rues au
quotidien mais pour rejoindre ce que
disait Lucile Schmith moi je pense qu'il
ne faut pas sous-estimer la possibilité
Gabriel Atal sache et peut-être
précisément je sais pas SS sont tant que
ça une relation de confiance d'ailleurs
aussi une relation d'intérêt très bien
compris mais Édouard Philippe vous savez
a poussé Emmanuel Macron à prendre
beaucoup de mauvaises décisions ou l'
entretenu dans ses mauvaises décisions
les appels en même temps que les ISF les
80 km/h maintenir la taxe carbone sans
têter dans le maintien contre la taxe
àonne maintenir le premier tour des
élections municipales il y avait un
accord avec la CFDT sur le la réforme
des retraites réintroduire du
paramétrique dans une réforme systémique
bref donc si on peut concevoir un
Premier ministre qui a été une forme de
entre guillemets mauvais génie on peut
en concevoir un alors même qu'on vous
répéter en permanence qu'il n'y avait
pas le début d'une feuille de papier à
cigarette entre les deux hein c'était
toujours ce qu'eddard Philippe de sa
relation avec Emmanuel Macron on peut
imaginer qu'il est un meilleur génie
entre guillemets encore faut-il qu'emel
Macron accepte d'être sauvé malgré lui
un tout petit mot làdessus petit point
effectivement dans les enquêtes
d'opinion c'est extrêmement rare que les
Français expriment ouvertement dans les
enquêtes qualitatives des nuances de des
différences de perception voir des
conflits entre un premier ministre et un
président par ailleurs ditesab n pas de
Lig c'est vrai mais pour les Français il
a il a une méthode qui lui a permis ce
phénomène d'opinion c'est-à-dire il sa
méthode c'est deux points il dit les
choses les constats il est pas dans le
dé on souvient au moment du classement
PISA et l'action la transformation le
fait qu'il est beaucoup agit ça rappelle
un peu le Sarkozi des années Bovo mais
c'est ce crédit de confiance qui a dans
qui qui doit peut-être essayer par
translation de mettre en place à matinon
même si les choses sont infiniment plus
difficiles c'est ce crédit de confiance
qui va pas changer je partage
complèement ce qu'à dit Sébastien Ferjou
les grandes inquiétudes l'angoisse du
déclin la difficulté des Français à se à
se projeter l'école ou l'hôpital mais
qui peut créer une sorte de climat de
confiance un choc psychologique qu'il
faut pas négliger euh alors il y a il y
a un grand thème dont on va parler dans
un instant et évidemment on y consacrera
du temps c'est le quak Amélie oua
Castera mais d'abord je voudrais rester
sur cette question de équilibre des des
relations entre le Président de la
République et son nouveau Premier
ministre et sur la marche de manœuvre de
Gabriel Atal grâce à Steve Jourdain qui
va nous rejoindre tout de suite sur ce
plateau il doit être juste là bonsoir
Steve on on s'est posé la question
comment Gabriel Attal peut-il
éventuellement contourner le Parlement
ou faire ce qu'il a fait au ministère de
l'éducation en 6 mois en 6 mois il na'a
fait passer aucune loi tout ce qu'il a
annoncé rue Grenel bien c'était en vertu
de son pouvoir dire réglementaire par
par exemple la fameuse interdiction de
la BAA a été prise sous forme de
circulaire ce pouvoir règlementaire il
est prévu aux articles 34 et 37 de notre
Constitution en tant que Premier
ministre en tant que Premier ministre il
pourra à présent agir par décret un
décret c'est une décision qui est prise
par écrit et qui ne relève pas de la loi
ça ne concerne que certains domaines par
exemple il sera impossible pour Gabriel
Attal de prendre des décrets pour
modifier la date des élections ou encore
de légiférer en matière de préservation
de l'environnement ou encore de réformer
notre droit du travail avec une limite
oui un décret ne peut jamais contredire
une loi seul une loi peut modifier une
loi il y a une raison politique assez
limite la loi c'est la norme suprême de
notre hiérarchie juridique elle est
votter par les élus de la nation
contrairement aux ministres qui sont
simplement nommés et donc si je vous
entends Gabriel Atal va pouvoir
éternellement multiplier les décrets il
devra sans doute passer par la case
Parlement il devra faire de la politique
et puis depuis elliisabeth borne la
donne n'a pas vraiment changé le Premier
ministre ne dispose pas de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale il va
donc falloir tenter de composer de faire
des deals de passer des compromis le
groupe politique qui devrait à nouveau
être sollicité par Gabriel Attal c'est
le groupe LR le fameux groupe LR et
c'est 62 députés un accord de coalition
n'est toujours pas à l'ordre du jour
mais on imagine et bien que comme
Élisabeth borne il va tenter de
convaincre ses élus de droite de voter
sur certains textes au cas par cas si
pas parvient pas et bien il pourra
toujours leur tordre un petit peu le
bras en utilisant des outils que et bien
les Français connaissent désormais très
bien Thomas l'article 493 de la
Constitution qui permet et bien
d'adopter un texte sans vote l'article
49 44 alinéa 3 qui permet d'un vote sur
le texte choisi par le gouvernement à
l'exclusion de tous les amendements
retenus par le Parlement ça s'appelle la
procédure du vote bloqué ou encore le
temps législatif programmé qui permet de
fixer en amont le temps d'examen d'un
texte en en séance autant d'outils
législatifs qui font depuis quelques
mois depuis ellizabeth borne partie du
quotidien des Français merci beaucoup
Steve Jourdain pour toutes ces
explications lucide Schmith il a ce soir
à l'Élysée vers 19h30 Emmanuel Macron
qui reçoit les les parlementaires de de
sa majorité est-ce qu'il est pas là déjà
le premier enjeu parce que elle a été en
partie secouée par le la loi immigration
cette majorité oui exactement et puis on
sait que elle a été secouée on se
rappelle de de l'image je Sacha oulier
le président de la commission des lois
qui euh qui n'a pas voté qui n'a pas
voté cette loi euh on se rappelle du
président du groupe modem qui s'est
abstenu donc on a vu que il y a la
majorité s'est secouée et on a vu
qu'elle était aussi assez secouée par ce
gouvernement resserré c'est-à-dire que
par exemple le modem le partenaire
privilégié je rappelle que François beou
est est régulièrement sollicité par
Emmanuel Macron pour lui demander des
conseils le MoDem a fait part de son
trouble par rapport à ce gouvernement
resserré et je voudrais quand même
rappeler une chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui
cette loi a été déférée au Conseil
constitutionnel donc par Emmanuel Macron
et par l'opposition et qu'on n' pas
encore le résultat du de la la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel mais qu'on
sait déjà que elle réfutera sans doute
une vingtaine d'articles puisque et le
président de la République et l'ancienne
Premier ministre ont reconnu que ces
articles n'étaient pas conformes à la
Constitution donc on est dans une
situation on a une sorte de bombe à
retardement autour de cette loi
migration sachant que du coup que va
dire le rassemblement national il va
dire mais ça c'est une logique pour
changer la constitution parce qu'au fond
ce que dit cette loi c'est ce que
veulent les Français sur la question
migratoire donc ça va remettre le
rassemblement national en selle il y a
ce trouble au sein du MoDem et puis y a
ce trouble entre guillemets de ce qu'on
appelle l'aile gauche de la majorité
présidentielle personnellement je
m'interroge sur ce que ce que signifie
cette aile gauche si ce n'est ceux qui
ont été sorti du gouvernement à
l'exception de la ministre des
universités donc de plus en plus une
sorte de coquille vide Élisabeth borne
était censée appartenir à une aile
gauche également et au fond que signifie
appartenir à l'aile gauche de la
macronie que va devenir cette aile
gauche GAE de la macronie il y a un vrai
sujet là-dessus peut-il y avoir
descission ou et
voteront-ils tous les textes qui seront
présentés au Parlement je Sébastien
Ferjou elle existe encore à l'Assemblée
nationale C elle gauche mais oui parce
que les députés ne se sont pas toujours
évaporé et je ne crois pas que que
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières semaines les a beaucoup
encouragé à enfin les a beaucoup
rapproché du cœur du macronisme
finalement moi j'ai entendu Gabriel Atal
au moment et c'est là où on voit quand
même qu'il y a chez lui qui dépasse
peut-être une marge de manœuvre au
moment de la transmission de pouvoir il
disait je n'oublierai jamais que je fais
partie ou que je n'oublierai jamais que
je viens des rangs de cette majorité là
sous-entendu pas comme d'autres
ministres peut-être Gérald ramanin ou
d'autres qui finalement ou ministre venu
de la droite qui n'ont eu jamais ne se
sont jamais préoccupés des état d'ames
entre guillemets de l'aile gauche de la
majorité il n'y a pas d'ailleurs que la
fameuseelle gauche là vous en parliez
aussi le modem il y a aussi horizon
alors ça peut être pour des raisons qui
ne sont pas que des raisons politique
parce que finalement quelle est la vraie
distinction entre les ailes droites et
les ailes gauches c'est un peu plus dans
la posture hein c'est un peu plus dans
ce qu'on assume vis-à-vis de l'opinion
que réellement sur du fond politique le
vrai sujet c'est celui que vous évoquez
qui ne va pas que remettre le
rassemblement national en scène mais les
républicains aussi dé facto puisque
c'était la logique idéologique qu'il
défendait si vous voulez que les choses
changent il faut changer non pas l'état
de droit mais l'état du droit ce que la
macronie ne souhaite pas faire et donc
ces enjeux là ils restent présents
finalement l' gauche et l' droite qui se
retrouve sur ce point-là Frédéric Daab
est-ce que il y a il y a la l'équilibre
originel de de voilà du pouvoir
macroniste il est toujours présent dans
l'opinion est-ce que les Français jugent
que il y a eu une dérive à droite comme
le disait Mathieu tout à l'heure ou que
euh voilà ça marche toujours sur les
deux gens ou une évolution une oui une
voilà je dirais je dis un glissement un
glissement dérive est un
petit dire que ce remaniement a collé un
peu plus à la base électorale des Macron
si je prends en compte le premier tour
de l'élection euh en fait présidentielle
bah l'opinion ne ne ne raisonne pas en
elle gauche en aelle droite même si
objectivement il y a un vrai travail à
faire du côté d'Emmanuel Macron et de
gabrial pour rassurer C aux grandes
réforme ouiou voilà réforme des
retraites loi immigration tout à fait
loi avec de manières très différentes la
réforme des retraites un rejet très fort
et une petite une majorité assez courte
d'électeurs d'manuel Macron à peine 2
tiers qui soutenaient cette réforme des
retraite loi immigration où le cvage
gauche-doite s'est complètement effondré
puisqu'il y avait des vraies convergces
entre sympathisant de droite
sympathisant de gauche et sympathtisan
macroniste mais euh je dirais que le le
glissement à droite je dirais que c'est
pas enfin comment coller l'étiquette
gauche- droite appréhender l'action du
gouvernement à travers le prisme de la
gauche et de la droite c'est de moins en
moins ce que font les Français je ne dis
pas que le cltivage GA droite a a
disparu mais sur de très nombreux su suj
notamment les sujets régaliens les
grands sujets de société même sur
l'économie ce ce clivage s fortement
onent à l'efficacité dont vous parz
touour sur une logqueefficacité par
contre là avec le bilan voilà là où
vraiment il y a un trouble sur ce
quiétait le macronisme originel et ce
trouble je dirais à pollué à gêner ou
gâché les de premières années du second
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que un
les Français ne veulent plus de ce
gouvernement des experts de ce
gouvernement de techniciens où les les
personnalités du gouvernement
n'incarnent pas ce remanement c'est
peut-être la suite du du remanement du
mois de juillet oùmanuel Macron et
Madame borne ont sorti papendia
Jean-Christophe combe François Bron des
ministres qui qui faisaient peutêtre du
bon mais qui n'incarnait rien et
qui n'était pas visible et deuxièmement
le fameux en même temps c'est devenu
pour les Français non pas on dépasse
l'équivage on prend les solutions les
plus efficaces de gauche et droite mais
en même temps c'est un signe
d'hésitation c'est un signe de
tergiversation et c'est un signe
d'inaction il faut pas oublier que
Emmanuel Macron a fini l'année avec
l'idée que il était inactif que l'action
de son son action était vu comme une
action veine c'était des critiques qui
ne lui étaient jamais qui n avaient
jamais été adressé depuis 2017 alors et
puis juste un mot mais finalement oui
sur la méthode enfin c'est ce que je
disais il y a quand même le bilan c'est
la prétenension à l'efficacité elle Sete
quand même au bilan et je pense que le
dépassement n'était jamais que minse
gouvera mieux que des gens qui avaient
pris la peine de se faire élire et qui
connaissait les Français est-ce que
cette gouvernance là a mieux marché je
ne crois pas que ce soit l'impression
qu'on a gardé les Français alors les
premiers pas de ce nouveau gouvernement
àal évidemment freiné par un boulet
nommé Amélie oua Castera la nouvelle
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesses des sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques a justifié
vous le savez le choix de placer ses
enfants dans une école privée par les
absences répétées des professeurs dans
le public ce matin encore elle tentait
d'éteindre
l'incendie je ne veux pas aller plus
avant sur le terrain de la vie
personnelle et de la vie privée
euh il y a eu des attaques auxquelles
j'ai essayé de répondre avec le plus de
de sincérité possible et je pense que il
faut clore ce chapitre là des attaques
personnelles et de la vie personnelle ce
que je peux vous dire et je m'arrêterai
là c'est
[Musique]
que jamais mon mari et moi n'avons
priorisé autre chose que le bien-être de
notre enfant moi je crois en école de la
République je crois en l'école publique
je crois qu'il faut tous que nous ayons
beaucoup d'ambitions pour elle c'est ça
que je vais dire ce matin l'amertume
pour ne pas dire la colère reste forte
dans le discours des principaux
syndicats d'éducation nationale on
écoute le secrétaire général de la FSU
c'est justement à l'issue d'une
rencontre avec la nouvelle ministre je
ne sais pas si on a déjà démarré aussi
mal une prise de fonction en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale le
faossé qu'il y a entre le ministère et
les agents du service public qui est
déjà existant hein il y a une grande
défiance vis-à-vis de l'institution il y
a un manque de reconnaissance qui est
quelque chose de structurel de profond
elle l'a aggravé elle l'a confirmé et ce
qu'elle nous dit ce matin n'est pas de
nature à améliorer les choses on lui a
dit toute la difficulté qu'on aurait à
discuter des sujets de fond avec cette
ministre dans ce contexte-là alors même
qu'elle ne prend aucun engagement sur
les dossiers prioritaires selon la
profession qui donnerait des gages
justement de d'une volonté d'aller de
l'avant et de de faire autrement à
savoir les salaires les conditions de
travail ce ne sont pas les seuls sujets
qui sont posés mais ce sont des sujets
prioritaires lucide Schmith est-ce qu'on
touche déjà les les limites d'un d'un
gouvernement resserré des super
ministres multicasquette je pense que si
vous voulez il y a toutes ces questions
de casting il faut que ce soit paritaire
là il y a eu tous les commentaires aussi
sur le fait que c'était les hommes qui
occupaient les postes les plus
importants les postes régaliens donc il
fallait des femmes et le grand ministère
on le confie à Amélie oua Castera et
c'est elle qui fait un faux pas au bout
de 48 heures et je voulais quand même
dire une chose sans rester trop
longtemps sur ce cas c'est qu'il faut
quand même prendre l'habitude lorsqu'on
est ministre ne pas seulement parler de
sa vie personnelle c'est elle qui a
parlé de sa vie personnelle et de ses
enfants c'estàdire qu'on doit
s'occuper des enfants de tout le monde
donc le sujet c'est au fond un une
discussion sur intérêt général intérêt
particulier et au fond la capacité à
tenir un discours politique ça montre
que l'éducation nationale on le sait est
un ministère compliqué ça montre
d'ailleurs le talent qu'a pu avoir
Gabriel Atal de passer entre les gouttes
euh mais du coup alors même que le
premier ministre est parti en disant
j'emmène avec moi la la cause de
l'éducation nationale alors même qu'elle
a un un un grand ministère dans lequel
il y a aussi comme vous le disiez il y a
la jeunesse le sport les Jeux Olympiques
enfin ça fait quand même beaucoup alors
que l'éducation nationale est en
difficulté moi je pense que c'était une
mauvaise idée de faire ce grand
ministère on voit que ça a été quelque
chose de pensé d'une manière dire une
stratégie de communication et au fond la
difficulté à laquelle on va se heurter
sur l'éducation nationale c'est que
c'est un ministère on n' pas besoin de
faire des lois et ça a été dit et redit
vous l'avez démontré au fond Gabriel
Atal peut gouverner sans faire de loi
dans la période qui vient mais il a
devant lui des des des dossiers
politiques gagner les européennes en
tout cas faire en sorte de limiter les
dégâts et puis y a ce sujet d'emmener
avec lui l'éducation nationale qui déjà
est fragilisé donc on voit que ce qui se
passe ce sont plutôt des fauxas qui
tiennent je trouve à l'accumulation des
coûts comme je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que c'est bien de nommer
Gabriel Attal Premier ministre c'est un
coût mais ensuite quand on veut faire
trop de coups à la fois on réfléchit pas
suffisamment à la profondeur des
dossiers et il y a un enjeu comme ça a
été rappelé à plusieurs reprises sur
l'attente de résultats de contenu alors
ça va l'économie française va pas se
redresser à cause de Gabriel Atal he je
voudrais quand même le dire je pense
qu'elle se redressera parce que les
entrepreneurs la croissance l'Europe et
cetera mais en tout cas sur des sujets
régaliens il est clair qu'on attend sur
l'éducation nationale particulièrement
des résultats parce que il a pour lui le
bénéfice du doute il est resté 6 mois et
ça s'est bien passé mais tout le monde
sait queil a très bien communiqué en 6
mois mais qu'il a pas pu faire
grand-chose ouais et alors bon
évidemment les journalist FT leur
travail ils enquêtent sur les
déclarations de de d'améou Castera donc
confire de libération sont allés
chercher l'ancienne institutrice d'un de
ses enfants voilà qui on va dire a une
version un peu différente de celle de de
la nouvelle ministre comment elle peut
sortir d'une telle spirale négative
d'après vous Jean Sébastien Ferjou
est-ce que c'est encore possible je ne
sais pas je pense c'est une sorte
d'accident industriel parce que elle s'y
prend très mal à mon sens oui bien sûr
c'est une bourde après elle répondait à
une question ce n'est pas d'elle-même
qu'elle éprouvé le besoin de parler de
la scolarité de ses enfants et une
question qui était assez pernicieuse
parce que c'était pas seulement vos
enfants sont scolarisés dans le privé si
ils sont scolarisés dans cet
établissement là dont on sait que la
ligne éducative ou idéologie qui s'y
déploie est très conservatrice donc en
CRE vous interr juste une minute pour
dire que c'est une question classique à
tous les ministres d'éducation nationale
non mais je suis absolument d'accord
avec vous il est inv vrais semblable
qu'elle n'it pas été préparé à cette
question là c'est en ça je vous dis
c'est accident industriel parce que de
deux choses l'une soit vous êtes dans la
transgression vous assumez la
transgression tout àure nous disait on
les on attendait gabrielal sur le parler
vrai ben on était on pouvait on pouvait
aussi dire on est en PL dans le parl en
tout cas ça pit jus mais c'est là où je
voulais en venir c'est-à-dire que c'est
une catastrophe vis-à-vis des syndicats
et on sait que le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale est quand même
assez largement un ministère de
cogogestion et c'est là où je suis
d'accord avec vous beaucoup de gens on
dit OUI Gabriel n'a rien fait si il a
réussi quand même à imposer des
décisions qui n'étaient pas forcément
accueillies si favorablement que ça par
l'administration de l'éducation ou par
les personnels de l'Éducation nationale
et s'est passé sans trop de crispation
là elle elle s'est mis direct le corps
et on peut comprendre les les
enseignants mais il y avait un moyen de
s'en sortir c'était de prendre l'opinion
à témoins parce que ça n'a choqué
personne en France je pense il y a
tellement de dizaines de centaines de
milliers de parents qui ont pris la même
décision donc le problème c'était la fin
de la phrase qui manquait c'est elle
elle aurais pu dire en tant que parent
d'élèv je mesure mieux enfin je mesure à
quel point les défis sont immenses pour
pour l'école publique et je mettrai
toute mon énergie pour donner à l'école
publique les moyens qui lui sont encore
une fois par de résultat ça fait ça fait
7 ans que Maron aurit pu par une
pirouette prendre les Français à Trans
la transgression ça va être extrêmement
compliqué parce que oui la seule réponse
à faire c'était pour des raisons
personnelles comme beaucoup de familles
j'ai fait le choix de mettre mes enfants
dans le privé et ça n'appartient qu'à
moi en fonction des enfants des familles
des confession les un et les autres
voilà basta mais le problème c'est
qu'elle a Dévé derrière en disant j'ai
j'ai fait ça parce que les profs sont
jamais remplacés et puis j'ai fait ça
parce que mes enfants sont heureux
épanouis en sécurité donc elle tient un
propos politique derrière profondément
politique et non plus du tout personnel
et un propos politique qu'elle n'assume
pas souvenez-vous Claude Allegre lui il
arrive il dit il faut dégraisser le
mammouth il parle d'ailleurs à l'époque
plutôt de l'administration centrale et
pas du nombre de professeurs mais c'est
un propos politique qu' l'assume lui dit
moi je connais la machine d'intérieur je
je vais vous dire il faut dégraisser le
mamouth et ça lui vaudra franchement de
gros soucis par la suite
par exactement comme l' rappelé
jeanébastien on on est dans la
cogestionéducation nationale même les
mouvements des personnels sont cogérés
donc c'est vous dire le niveau de
cogestion donc si vous arrivez en
mettant un coup de boule à tous les
agents sur le thème vous êtes desféants
parce que vous vous êtes trop absent et
vous n'êtes jamais remplacé et puis en
plus les gamins chez vous pas
épanou évidemment comme ça
que elle n' pas corriger le tir elle est
sur une ligne défensive elle vient même
à expliquer maintenant qu' fait elle est
pas que c'était même pas pour des
raisons de confession et ce donc quand
vous êtes non mais ça s'appelle le
tobogan dépasser par la transgression
vis-à-vis des Français claud marquer des
points vis-à-vis d'une partie de
l'opinion elle elle marque visà de
personne question à Fr GAB est-ce que la
solution c'est de nommer un ministre
délégué finalement très fort une
personnalité qui va voilà la place quoi
déjà une première solution c'est une
forme de silence de sa part parce que je
partage complètement ce qu' dit Jean
Sébastien Ferjou ce qu'elle a raconté
alors malade droitement vous avez très
bien dit les choses c'est le fait et on
le voit dans nos enquêtes on interroge
les Français sur l'école de dizaines de
milliers pour pas dire de centaines de
milliers de parents d'élèves il faut pas
oublier moi j'ai été frappé par un
décalage saisissant quand Gabriel Atel
était ministre de l'Éducation entre des
propos des Français sur l'école
absolument catastrophique en terme de
déclin en terme de dégradation pour la
première fois dans les enquêtes qu'on
pose de manière récurrente c'était pas
seulement le collège et le lycée qui
allait moins bien c'était l'école
maternelle et l'école primaire le score
de dégradation est devenu majoritaire
donc vraiment une école qui tombe il
faut pas oublier que le discours sur le
sur le déclin français se cristallise
sur deux institutions l'hôpital l'école
et face à ça on a eu des indicateurs
très favorable à Gabriel natal sur la
confiance qu'on lui qu'on lui
manifestait sur les les actions qu'il a
fait parce qu'il a quand même un bilan
en 6 mois et quand on demande aux
Français de restituer le harcèlement sa
prre prise de parole la BAA les dates du
bac le redoublement la veille de sa
nomination ou l'avant-veille le décret
sur le brevet des collèges qui va
devenir non pas un concours mais un vrai
examen donc il y a pour Gabriel Atal un
point de fragilité ces premiers pas à
matinon sont plutôt salués mais apporter
la cause de déécole à Matignon il en
faudra plus les Français attendent
qu'ils prennent ce dossier à bras cor
est-ce que ça passe par ça passé par une
première par une ministre très occupé
sur je olympiques et qui aurait pu lui
laisser du champ ça passe peut-être
comme vous dit
ou Lucile Schmid votre avis d'ailleurs
on peut faire le parallèle entre
éducation et santé il y a peut-être là
une erreur originelle dans la formation
de son gouvernement recerré qui est de
ne pas nommer de ministres de plein
droit sur deux thématiques qui sont vous
nous le dites de des thématiques
prioritaires pour les Français qume
étant a tout à fait raison et puis je
voudrais quand même dire que dans notre
échange on voit bien a quelque chose qui
monte c'est la dissociation entre les
préoccupations des parents et les
préoccupations des professeurs
c'est-à-dire que lorsque les parents au
fond sont inquiets du niveau de l'école
ou comment leurs enfants sont traités il
faut aussi mesurer la difficulté du
métier des professeurs je rappelle qu'il
y a quand même deux professeurs qui ont
été assassinés donc dans ces conditions
la crise d' voocation du côté des
professeurs faire appel à l'opinion
publique et aux parents d'élèves ça ne
veut pas dire oublier les professeurs et
on voit non mais je sais mais il y a une
tentation il y a une tentation là-dessus
on voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui moi
j'ai appartenu à plusieurs conseils
d'administration de lycée gérer à la
fois les préoccupations des professeurs
et des parents d'élèves ça devient de
plus en plus difficile pour ceux qui
administrent l'éducation nationale et il
faut faire les deux à la fois après
après il y a un sujet sur les services
publics vous avez raison tout à fait
Thomas HUG et et là-dessus on sait très
bien que Marine Le Pen a récupéré le
sujet des services publics par rapport à
la gauche qu'elle qu'elle le maîtrise et
ça c'est c'est un vrai sujet pour
Emmanuel Macron parce que je rappelle
que l'idée c'est aussi de nommer Gabriel
Atal pour faire pièce donc comme je le
rappelais au rassemblement national dans
la dans la première échéance électorale
qui vient et cette question de la
dégradation des services publics c'est
un sujet sur lequel le rassemblement
national ne cesse de marquer des points
plus que la gauche et c'est un sujet
d'ailleurs aussi pour la gauche et il y
a il y a un sujet de posture politique
je disais elle s'est mis sur ligne de
défensive mais regardez Gabriel Atal
samedi il est en déplacement avec
Catherine vauterin on lui pose une
question sur le passé de Madame Vautrin
qui manifestait au côté de la manif pour
tous il ne s'est pas troublé il n'a pas
cédé à l'intimidation idéologique il a
pas perdu ses moyens il ne s'est pas mis
à s'excuser il a juste assumé circuler
il y a rien à voir et finalement la
polémique alors peut-être qu'elle
intéressait d'ailleurs plus grand monde
ça renvoyé mais non mais c'est loin
d'être an
par ministère ucation nationale c'était
ça et c'est ça qui permet de résister au
rassemblement national justement c'est
de dire la perception qu'on les Français
ne doit pas être prise en otage par
certains acteurs très idéologisés qui
détournent le débat public finalement il
nous reste allez de 2 minutes et je
voudrais quand même qu'on parle de de
cette annonce faite par Gérald armanin
dans une interview dans un article du
Figaro il dit grosso modo sa mission
place Bovo elle sera terminée après les
Jeux Olympiques après les j un CYC au
ministère de l'Intérieur sera à atteint
Frédéric Daab c'est c'est quand même un
petit défi à l'autorité de de Gabriel
Attal on peut expliquer ça comme ça oui
c'est surtout assez inédit qu'un
ministre de lui-même signe sa finitude
comme on dit c'estàd déjà déjà il lui
qui annon
rest donc a une certaine cohérence
là-dessus même si je pense que pour
l'opinion publique oui après les Jeux
Olympiques si comme tout le mondepère
les choses se passe bien du point de vue
de la sécurité il y aura peut-être une
fin de cycle pour pour un ministre de
l'Intérieur qui resta relatif longtemps
qui a pas battu des records par rapport
à des prédécesseurs mais effectivement
je pense pas que les Français vont être
polarisés par cette petite phrase mais
c'est un oui c'est peut-être un petit
défi à l'autorité présidentielle et à
l'autorité du Premier ministre c'est
vrai qu'un des éléments qu'on devra
regarder c'est la capacité gbale à
travailler à mettre en musique sa
méthode c'est-à-dire dire les choses
agir transformer et ses relations avec
les les poids lourds du gouver ement on
a vu au moment de sa nomination une mou
de la part de Gérald d'manin et un tweet
lapidaire Bruno ler qui lui met la main
sur l'épaule il faut pas non plus
surinterpréter ces signes et j'ai envie
de dire beaucoup de Français sont Mor et
perd il faut vraiment dire ça que mais
c'est effectivement il de lui-même c'est
une manière aussi de se mettre une
pression et réussir j'ai envie
d'être tout dernier mot Jean Sébastien
je c'est aussi une manière de décaler le
sujet alors il est très habile
politiquement Géral enfin pour les
Français le quotidien c'est pas les Jeux
Olympiques bien sûr qu'il y a un enjeu
sécuritaire sur les Jeux Olympiques bien
sûr que les projecteurs seront braqués
sur la France à ce moment-là mais il y a
quand même ce que vivent les Français au
quotidien la dégradation on l'a vu dans
la publication des chifs de l'insécurité
ça c'est l'enjeu ce cycle là est-il
terminé non je n'ai pas du tout
l'impression qu'il soit terminé merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat Lucile Schmith je rappelle le
titre de votre livre Emmanuel Macron à
cont-temps livre qui est publié aux
éditions Bayar à bientôt sur sur public
scénna